Science, it gets in your head man, it gets
in your head and it ... changes things.
Hello DNews fans, Happy Anniversary Weekend!
Your friendly neighborhood neuroscientist
Crystal here.
I’ve hosted so many videos here for you
guys that I couldn’t even remember my first
one, but I’m told it was about memory and
optogenetics, which is not surprising because
they are two of my favorite things!
Optogenetics is the field of study where we
use genes that regulate a cell’s responses
to light to help us control events in a biological
system.
This gives researchers the ability to literally
control the minds of laboratory animals.
Turning brain regions on and off allow us
to isolate the function of these regions and
better understand how they drive specific
behaviors.
The technique has been used to study all kinds
of phenomena including hunger, fear, and even
social behaviors.
And as we saw in the paper Trace and I discussed
in that first video two years ago, optogenetics
can even be used to manipulate the memories
stored in our brain.
Which is a good thing if we’re beginning
to forget …
Alzheimer’s disease is a common cause of
brain degeneration, and it typically begins
with loss of memory and other impairments
in cognitive function.
Until recently, it was difficult for scientists
to discriminate between impairments in how
memories are stored and the inability for
Alzheimer’s patients to retrieve their stored
memories, so scientists at RIKEN and MIT went
about using optogenetics to find out.
In a paper published in 2016, researchers
took mice that had been genetically modified
to have an Alzheimer's-like condition and
to be responsive to optogenetic manipulation,
and taught them to be afraid of something.
Then, they split them into two groups.
One group did not receive optogenetic treatment
and the other one did.
Then both groups of mice were re-exposed to
what what they were taught to be afraid of.
The untreated group forgot they were supposed
to be afraid, but the other group didn't!
The differences in memory retention were the
result of changes in special memory cells
in the hippocampus region of the brain.
These particular cells have spiky bumps on
them, located on a part of the cell called
the dendrite.
The spiky bumps make up what is called the
“dendritic spine” -- think of it like
the spine in your back, which has bumps from
the vertebrae.
These are crucial to our brain’s ability
to adapt and learn.
When these spikes go away like they do in
Alzheimer’s disease, so do the memories
in the cells that express them.
Optogenetic treatment can prevent or reduce
this loss.
In this study, scientists used a fiber optic
cable to stimulate the memory cells with blue
light.
Now remember, the mice they were using had
been genetically modified to have optically
responsive neurons.
This kind of treatment wouldn’t work with
any old mouse you found on the street.
We know that the treatment worked because
the memory cells of the mice maintained spinal
density, and the mice retained their memory
of fear!
This indicates that this type of treatment
could, one day, be an effective strategy for
treating memory loss in the early stages of
Alzheimer’s disease.
Because optogenetics requires genetic modifications
in the cells, the technique can currently
only being applied to animals in the laboratory,
but with the rapid advancement of genome editing
by CRISPR/Cas9 and new advancements in getting
these genetic modifications into the brain,
this science might be inside your head before
you know it.
The results of scientific investigation made
possible by optogenetics have widespread implications
for the treatment of many human conditions.
Two years ago, we were discussing possible
therapy for PTSD, this year it’s Alzheimer's
Disease.
It will be exciting to see what progress we
can make toward understanding memory and how
to manipulate it in the next two years.
But for now, if you’re like me and can’t
remember that first video.
Here’s an opportunity to remember.
What’s your favorite memory?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments down below.
Thanks for watching!